what do you feel like the best lesson
other than her being so supportive I
imagine you're like that with your kids
because you you were taught that from a
young age but what do you think the
biggest lesson you got from her was oh
believe in yourself yeah cuz we grew up
in a really poor neighborhood with not
much and you know there was no reason
for me to believe that I was going to be
here and make it but she always
instilled in me believe in yourself you
could do whatever you want that I
instill that in my kids and I believe it
that's incredible cuz not all parents do
that you know what I'm saying like when
I was a kid she instilled in us that you
help people now people are less
fortunate you help people who need help
yeah I tell the story about my brother I
guess I was 10 probably not 10 I was
probably seven or eight my brother was
14 and he went to we had this this
couple that lived in our neighborhood
and the husband was in the Navy MH and
so he went away on the ship and the yard
was grown up and my brother went home
went over and cut her grass and he gave
she gave him $10 and he came home
bragging about the $10 he got and my mom
whooped his butt and told him you take
that $10 back down and you give it back
to her because we don't help people for
money we help people to help people and
that was just something oh wow you got a
great
mom wow very very lucky well we have a
little surprise for you and I was very
excited to be able to do this yeah you
don't know he really doesn't know about
it this is not TV this is real um for
for your many many charitable efforts
over the years and for helping those who
need help CMA is actually honoring you
as humanitarian of the
Year oh my
goodness wow I was so that's awesome
wow
wow I really did not know that I know I
was like no he really doesn't know I did
not know
[Music]
[Applause]
that thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home m